thank you kids are good yeah kids are
good I'm good are you coming to tip mm I
don't think I'll be coming to know it's
Toronto's your second home for my
singing uh Patel et Canada no I've got a
movie that I'm shooting in September
with Pete in Boston um and then uh and
I'm coming out until hug around
Thanksgiving or Christmas okay I'll come
and do us that visit how's that music
feel so short sitting back up Marc I'm
gonna sit like this the whole time
I think that's gonna discomforts of the
marijuana if you breathe in you posture
ever get your shoulders back and then
they'll keep it moving more we both sit
like this do the whole interview
supposed to sit like this and stand like
this all the time from this posture
okay you know that the iPhone social
media everything gets you like this
posture you have great posture
no no it's there's no question so far
maybe they do you the day for so long I
know it's been maybe 10 years you're
getting younger
thank you you - you look goodness I feel
like do you really no come on now LeBron
gross sure of you on on social media I
mean you probably in the best shape of
your life right now
I was during mile 22 and then I started
eating a lot of food in Atlanta and
drinking wine again but I'm about to
start getting in shape again so I go in
cycles that's good well you look good
you know thank you this movie you look
amazing - you're just really angry in
this movie yes it's you relieved all
that it's gone now yeah got it all out
right after that I did a family film but
Pete nah you know we made three movies
together they're all based on real-life
tragedies and that wasn't hard movies to
make and so we said you know at this
time let's do a fictional movie based on
real people in a world that you haven't
seen in an aid agency of our government
you hadn't seen but let's just go crazy
and have our idea of a good time in this
film and especially the fact that it's
kind of relatable to everything that's
happening right now
absolutely the bobblehead with Trump and
then you have a bomber there that that's
moment even though it's just a shot it
really experiences of what's happening
right now was that something you really
want to reflect in this film yeah I mean
look for me it was idea the original
idea was silver was like a second
villain you know and it's very small
part that I was going to do for like two
weeks and the more we started focused on
this character and you know with the
elections the ban and all this stuff you
know we kind of loved this voice of this
guy who just doesn't care
yeah and he's got an opinion about
everything and you know he's so
unapologetic and then it became the
focus of the film so anything with
political you know reminders of what's
happening today you got to take that up
with Pete and Leah yeah writer
you're living the American dream got a
dealership now named but Mark Wahlberg
have you sold a car I have you have good
salesperson I you know and I spoke to my
I don't do actual sales but I am
encouraged you know I've always been a
huge lover of cars my dream was as a kid
was to be able to go walk on a lot and
buy a first car which I remember like it
was yesterday when I bought my first car
and now to be able to provide a service
to people who Columbus Ohio and anybody
else who comes it's it's amazing for me
your daughter's 14 and I think it's 15
and a half in Ohio and you can start
driving yeah so she's gonna start
driving soon I'm gonna change that law
yeah I think it should be 21 21
boyfriend it's fine oh you know what
I've come to accept the fact that these
things are just going to happen it's
inevitable let go and let God
ballers thank you for host Wayne are you
doing I always ask you huh Duane is
killing it you know what his performance
this year I think will really you know
continue to surprise people he's just so
good on the show okay come to Toronto
okay I would love to Rasta Phil's come
back to work with me your ass don't
worry oh he's online now